get down everybody's gonna move that
feet
get down everybody's gonna leave that
seed don't die Nana Nana got out of that
dam and a Nana Nana you bad
[__] Monday the 6th of November
and guess what zero [__] are giving you
understand me zero [__] again
it's Monday and zero [__] are given you
understand me
uncle Joey in Monday November 6 swingin
dick and given how [__] I focus today
we're going strong this week
it's a beautiful [__] day to be
alive the bird chirping the clouds are
[__] not in the sky
I could see finally the clouds parted to
show the true colour of the [__] sky
you understand me
and that's what we're doing today we're
not taking no prisoners today we're
going straight ahead no [__] backing
up don't look back you understand we
don't even go back to get [__]
momentum we move straight today because
we don't give a [__] with the church
family you understand me we're bigger
than the [__] Gambino's were bigger
than coca-cola we got nothing but heart
and [__] balls today's Monday you
write your notes you write down your
gold you [__] do your twenty two
push-ups you have your little protein
shake and you go out there and you look
life in the [__] eye and you go you
know what you're gonna suck my dick
today you follow me anyway
the weed I'm smoking is beyond [__]
comparison when it comes with no label
on when they look at you in the weeds
don't go come to the back this is the
[__] you got a sign and you only get if
you got insurance you understand me it's
called The Devil's [__] brew only one
or two people have it
when I smoked it yesterday idea butan do
what a [__] speech in Russia that's
how deep this reefer tation but no
worries listen the New York Comedy
Festival is [__] sold out thank you
to your [__] savages thank you for
the church family it's sold out I can't
do nothing for you I'd like two cars per
ticket like a [__] family but you
know what I'll be back I'll be back in
February Jack don't give a [__] New York
you know I love you with all my
[__] heart beside that next
Tuesday for the church family you asked
for it you got it I need you
[__] I got a [__] show at
The Comedy Store Tuesday night at eight
o'clock I'm showcasing for Netflix this
is it we're gonna take over that [__]
place we're gonna pick up the dude from
Netflix and [__] a little fling up on
our shoulders and let him know if
anybody belongs on Netflix it's your
[__] uncle Joey but no worries once
they pull it up I'll let you know I'll
send you the link and we can [__]
attack and take over the [__] Tommy
Store that Tuesday night with tickets
without tickets that don't matter stars
will be flowing explosives will be going
through the [__] air then the week
after that my terrified improv the night
before Thanksgiving it don't get no
better than that you could bring your
grandmother down am I gonna curse [__]
yeah I'm gonna talk about eating that's
[__] yeah but you know what we're gonna
have a good time and that's all that
matters man
it's November already I don't know if
some of you [__] it thinking
get up get out
stand up for your right you don't say
Bob Marley said it best rum if you're
Latin oh yeah they want that it I want
that on a pinga you know I know I'm me
already
oh yeah any Latino know me law solid
white chorus on any level I'm bhutta na
mila pinga [__] that de sica - red
carpet under birthday I am anyway I
don't know what the [__] I said but I
just [__] said it W K and Z [__]
the Dutch station yeah we're back
[__] like I said it's Monday
[__] and it's up to you you can
either be a [__] doormat or you could
step on these [__] midgets of death
with their [__] [__] in their
skull cap because my head gets cold go
[__] yourself you and you [__] micro
dosing [__] you could all suck my
dick along with Kevin [__] Spacey
that [__] bird but I never liked that
[__]
from the [__] midnight a good enabled
the able side that little [__] prick
with his pompous [__] attitude that's
why he living in LA there's all these
little [__] walk around here like this
[__] don't stand at the end of the day
we all know we could take them into the
back room and there's no more [__]
tough guy
they'll be sucking your dick within two
[__] minutes like the rest of these
[__] much that's been my attitude
since day one I don't give a [__]
some guys you're gonna go who raised you
your mother didn't tell you the origin
that happens in the hotel is you suck
dick you gonna go to a hotel for a
[__] audition and try to con half
these [__] liberals oh my god go [__]
yourself you gotta get up every morning
look at yourself in the eye you want to
sell yourself for a movie and sup an old
dick we think that Bible force is in the
desk so you can [__] them read it after
you suck that sperm of debt and you can
[__] take the taste of cocktail your
mom we think that Bible was there for
people if that Bibles diabetes people
are oh no answer these [__] Hollywood
actresses after they sell their [__]
soul they could gargle on that [__]
but you're gonna juice and [__] him pray
that the sperm on that that paste the
[__] comes on a [__] mount me I don't
give a [__]
I've been five into ten [__] prizes
cuz I told them all to suck my dick
don't you [__] talk to me like that
[__] you put your legs on you put your
pants on one leg at a time that go see
and micro dosing that grows in makkal
doses you're the [__] captain curve
your [__] enterprise don't let nobody
tell you what the [__] to do you were
looking for a job
when you found that one when you talk to
me you talk to make a right [__]
because before I became a comic a felon
a [__] fool or drug addict I was a
[__] man but I always remained a
manner that's not the attitude you
leaving the house with today ya ain't
gonna make a dog you're a [__] man get
out there giggles are for [__] kids
and you know you look everybody near you
tell them what the [__] is on your mind
see they come [__] with you today
anyway I love you [__] with all
my heart
what a [__] my kid without you guys
I'd have dick nobody would come to my
shows nobody come see me I'm not one of
these [__] guys and oh you so get the
[__] out of here we fell it like it is
you I don't give a [__]
there ain't no safety net I look like a
[__] will ender do you [__] we
wake up in the morning we go for broke
you follow me we'll go for broke and we
don't play for [__] little toys and
cops and robbers we play for keeps when
you part of the [__] church you want
a [__] life place the [__] keeps
and stop with the [__] around and the
hahaha because there ain't no hahaha
sneeze when you're in a [__] casket
you understand me
so it's Monday wash your [__] pile that
nutsack look around salute the flag and
tell them all to suck your dick
to church tonight 8 o'clock Tuesday
night 8 o'clock that's it and that's
that the rest is up to you grab your
balls salute the flag and tell them I'm
not [__] around today and remember
always that getting get mama della be
hiya Bo can she not there mama la pena
book I feed their throng column or wrong
guy wrong copy no I love your mother
[__] stay black I have a great week
see you tonight 7:30 be there or be
square